Here we go.
Now I'm a baby.
I'm a baby now chat.
White day in labyrinth.
I hate this.
Why are there so many singing ladies?
Please!
I'm fucking- I'm fucking singing ladies!
Why is it always singing ladies?
Ladies!
Wait, how is it?
Okay, okay.
Okay, all right, all right, all right.
Is this supposed to be the re- what the fuck is this resolution?
I don't know.
What am I?
I don't even know what resolution I'm supposed to be.
Okay, this is it.
All right.
All right, the baby.
Now I'm a baby.
That- the baby's- Baby's not that scary!
Can't be scary!
Okay.
All right, okay, all right, all right.
It's not- okay.
All right, new story.
Can't hurt me.
I'm a fucking baby.
I love this game.
I've never met- yeah.
Yeah, babies can't scare me.
Okay, I need- I can- okay, walk.
Damn, I'm a fucking- I'm a smart baby.
But seriously, what the fuck is that?
What is- What is that?
What?
Oh, am I in the womb?
Oh my god, am I gonna get birthed?
What the- I'm gonna get birthed.
Right?
Oh, no.
I'm just just drinking water.
I'm just drinking water.
I was like, damn, that's cool.
I don't know what the fuck is this.
I just went through a traumatic experience with layers of fear.
I don't know shit right now.
I was going to be like, oh shit.
This is a scary game.
Every scary game starts in the womb.
Happy birthday, sweetie.
I'm so happy.
Wow, two of yours today.
Who the fuck would think it's some fucking water?
I don't know.
I think I know a little someone who's ready for some cake.
Yum yum.
Chugga chugga chugga chugga.
Chew chew.
Were you sad in all of this?
Here he comes.
Through the tunnel.
There's dad.
There he is.
Oh, there's dad.
Oh, she's sad.
I'll be...
Oh no.
Why is...
What are you doing?
Oh, dad.
Get out.
Get out, dad.
Am I sad?
Hey.
I can count too.
Look what I found.
Huh?
I wonder what it is.
Why don't we go upstairs?
Yeah, dad.
Where were you?
Huh?
Where were you when I was fucking drinking water and not being in the womb?
Oh my.
How much cake did you have?
Where's she taking me?
Oh god.
I don't wanna look at her face.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I still keep doing medics on the table.
Oh, it's getting dark.
Okay, there's monsters that chase me in this game.
That's all I know.
And like, you know what?
That's fine.
Like, fuck the psychological horror shit.
I'm done with that.
I don't care.
Just fucking chase me, monsters.
Like, I'd rather have monsters chase me than going through that bullshit again.
I'm a baby.
Oh, they just moved.
Look at all these boxes.
Shit, what the fuck?
This baby has such a big room.
This room is bigger than, like, my room.
Or maybe it's because I'm tiny that's why it looks big.
Okay, sweetie.
Baby's flexing hard.
Like, or maybe I'm just tiny.
It looks like you hate horror games.
Yes, I absolutely...
God, please.
I don't wanna look at you.
Yes, I...
Did you just see me rage quit a game after 20, 30 minutes?
Yes, I fucking hate horror games.
I hate horror games so much.
This is why it was a sub goal.
This is exactly why this was a sub goal.
Space to climb.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, there's shit to run.
I don't... Oh my god, she's so...
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I need a...
Dude, the sensitivity is actually crazy.
I don't... Dude, what the fuck is the sensitivity?
Where are you going?
Good morning.
Oh!
I was just wondering what the hell is happening.
You were scared of stairs.
Okay, here you go.
Uh...
Yeah, oh!
What?
What the fuck?
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
Is there something inside?
Get out.
Did I jump on it?
Do I... Do I...
Do I jump on it?
Wait, was... Oh, he was in the toy chest!
Oh, he was in the toy chest!
I just thought he was in the pillow!
I... I thought he was in the pillow!
Hello.
Hey.
What's your name?
Not much of a talker yet, eh?
The pillows are so...
jiggly.
Let's play a game.
Yeah, I thought the teddy bear...
I thought the teddy bear was in the pillow!
That's why I was like trying to... I was like, Oh, do I like fling it around?
And then he's gonna come out?
Baby.
Come here.
Turn around and cover your eyes.
Okay.
There.
You can look now.
Oh, that's cool!
What?
What do you want me to do?
I didn't listen to...
I didn't...
I didn't listen to what he said!
Wait, what did he want me to...
Oh!
Find the elephant!
I was like, What do you want me to do?
Oh, here?
Okay.
Is it here?
Super warm.
Oh, here you are!
Found it!
Is Teddy second at Cheap as Mom?
I mean, yeah.
He's like sewn in with patches and stuff.
And everything.
Dude, I can't even...
Holy shit.
Dude, this child...
This child has some...
Spooky ass toys.
This kid has so much shit.
Dude, what the fuck?
He has so many toys.
What do you want me to do?
Oh my gosh.
Animal, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I do appreciate it.
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay, I need to...
Give me a sec.
I need to turn up the volume of my game.
Because I had it turned up all the way to 7.
So I couldn't hear shit.
I couldn't...
What do you want me to do?
Do you think the music box still works?
Huh.
That's a nice melody.
What do you want me to do?
Is he gonna push me somewhere?
Oh, I crawl faster.
What the...
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Pay attention in the...
In the...
It's okay, I have chat to pay attention for me.
I can just do this.
Unless we reach water with our newly dug well, I think we'll have to bid each other fairly well.
Dude, what the fuck?
He has more toys here?
Why does he need all these books?
What's this for?
You're like fucking two!
Wait, I don't know how old kids are supposed to be.
I just...
Round and round and round.
Hey, pick me up and carry me on your back.
Okay.
I wanna show you something.
We meet someplace very dark.
He doesn't need all these books.
How about your closet?
Oh, true, true, true.
I know how old kids are supposed to be.
Shut the doors completely.
It has to be darker.
It has to be darker?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
Oh, oh, wait!
Why did the song change?
Hope there are no more...
What?
Why did the music change?
How do I hug you?
A little bit safer?
Okay...
Okay, I feel safe now.
I don't feel safe.
I...
What do you mean I don't feel safe?
I think we're...
What do you mean?
I hate this.
Okay, okay.
I'm not supposed to be here.
Oh!
What?
Oh, my God.
Okay, what does this family have?
Can you hear that?
Okay, fuck you bear.
I...
Fuck you, teddy bear.
I think something's coming.
Oh, God!
What are you doing in the closet?
I don't think we're supposed to be here!
Stupid fucking bear!
Bear's not a nice bear, confirmed.
God, please, I don't want to look at you.
Can't trust the bear.
Apparently not, because he was like, we're not supposed to be here!
God, please, I don't want to look at you.
Oh my god.
Rude ass bear lying about monsters and shit.
Dude, I already forgot his name.
I just know he's a piece of shit.
He's your fair- bear- I'm right now saying-
God, I hate this.
I hate this.
Please, stop singing!
Please, stop putting- please stop putting ladies singing!
Please!
How long
is this game chat?
How long is this game, guys?
Sing back to assert dominance?
Oh my god!
Preacher, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a butt heart!
What the fuck?
What the- what the fuck?
Five hours long?
If you- oh, so it'll just take me three hours.
Or two hours.
Am I moving?
Is my bed moving?
Oh, I hate this.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
Why do I need to peek around corners?
Huh?
How?
How do I peek?
It won't let me!
Why doesn't it let me peek around corners?
What?
Why is the M6?
Oh, I must be sta- oh.
Hey, look at that.
I did it.
I had to stat.
I'm baby.
I'm...
Awww.
I'm babyyyy!
What...
Please.
Awww!
Okay.
I'm baby.
I'm- no.
Don't...
Don't you...
Don't you fuck with me.
Don't you fuck with me, Rem!
Why is this atmospheric sound so... I hate this!
Why is the atmospheric sound so...
Why?
This is supposed to be psychological!
Looking... looking... looking...
I'm looking... I'm looking!
Why?
Is there another baby crying?
Why is there another baby crying?
Why did I wait until 2am to play this game?
Okay, RwC Amateurs is getting to her.
Konichiwa!
Ninten, shut the fuck up.
I can't!
A baby!
Why is this so scary?
Okay, okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
Okay.
FUCK IT.
OH!
THE SHADOW!
Love you.
Love you, man.
I got scared by the shadow!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Why is... why is he crying?
Why are you crying?
Please stop crying, please!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, give me a sec guys.
Oh, wait is my teddy bear here?
Wait, how do I... Teddy bear!
How do I... Teddy!
Teddy!
Oh my god, Teddy!
How do I get Teddy out?
How do I get you out, Teddy?
Oh, I plugged you... oh yeah, yeah I'm so sorry.
Power, power.
Oh god.
Oh sorry, I'm not okay, I'm dying.
I'm not okay, I'm freaking out here.
I'm just hiding behind this washer.
Alright, Teddy.
Alright, you stupid rock.
Oh!
What the fuck!
Teddy, this is... I scared him.
Oh my god, his eyes actually scared me when he... when the eyes looked at me and I looked back.
I freaked out.
I can't... I wish I could stay in my sleep, I'd be brave and hang in there.
Noticity.
Okay, goodnight, Noticity.
Goodnight.
Oh, oh, Teddy.
There is nothing for you now.
I don't like that wording.
For you now.
Alright, chat.
Alright.
You know what?
Toy.
Oh.
Oh, should I plug you back in?
Okay, apparently...
Okay.
Okay, now run.
Ah!
Wait.
No!
Please!
Please keep crawling!
Baby!
You're baby!
You're a babe!
Oh, baby, why can't you crawl?
Why can't you crawl, baby?
I'm safe.
Am I not supposed to be here?
Did I fuck up?
Wait, aren't you suppo- Oh, I didn't find mom?
Dude, what the fuck?
Why didn't you find mom?
Just stay inside!
Okay.
Uh.
Fine.
Oh, no!
Mom can do whatever she wants!
I have to run back out?
No!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
Baby.
Strong baby!
Okay.
We're here for support.
Baby strong.
I hate this.
I hate the sounds.
I hate all the sounds it's making.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, no thing.
Uh.
Ah!
Okay.
Strong baby.
Strong.
Baby, you're strong!
God.
Oh, god.
Not the stairs.
No.
Not stairs again.
Not stairs!
Oh.
Ah!
Fucking shut up!
Can't you find us?
God.
Fucking bear!
Ah!
Oh, saving.
Why is it saving?
It's just it's...
Run?
Run where?
Up?
Oh, I hate this.
I hate this.
Up.
Down.
Kicked.
Above it.
Ahhh!
Woah.
It's just it's just...
Why is my heart beating so fast?
What is this?
Baby...
Oh, my god.
Baby run.
Baby running.
Baby!
What the fuck?!
Baby close.
Baby.
Why can't I close this?
Why can't I close you?
Baby close!
I can't hear me.
I'm not seeing.
Okay.
Baby open.
Baby.
Baby where?
Where baby?
Baby open.
Open baby.
Okay.
No more?
Oh shit.
Dude why the fuck are you... baby.
What the fuck am I doing up here?
Oh do I go to the fridge?
What the fuck am I doing?
Big open... open?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just climbing.
I'm just...
Baby just climb against...
Okay.
Oh I get it.
Oh!
Oh no.
Okay.
No.
What the fuck does baby supposed to do?
What is baby supposed... oh chair.
Chair?
Oh!
I'm supposed to get the chair.
What's over there?
Who are you?
That's your mom.
That's my mom?
Okay.
Legit I got to see it.
Oh!
Oh that was cold.
Oh god!
It was cold.
I hate this.
The man... I freaking... I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Fuck this coat.
Fuck this coat chat.
Oh my god.
You guys... programs you to be free to coat some big sense at least.
Okay.
I just need to close my eyes.
I'm run.
I have to... Okay.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm running.
Baby run.
Baby.
Baby no.
Baby keep running.
Baby.
Why?
Baby no.
Baby.
Baby just keep crawling baby.
Baby please.
Just keep crawling baby.
Baby.
Baby just keep crawling baby.
Baby, where do I go?
Baby, where you go?
Okay, baby climb.
Okay.
Keep climbing, baby.
Keep climbing.
I got this, baby.
I got this.
Okay, where...
Where did baby go?
Where did...
Oh!
Okay, that was...
That was an a... hey, shoes.
Shoes.
Why is baby tired?
Oh, further?
Baby, pull.
Oh!
Okay.
Ha-ha.
I'm a smart baby.
Baby smart.
Poopy!
Cold store.
Cold store!
I don't like this.
I hide.
Okay.
Can't hurt me anymore.
I'm just staying in here.
They can't hurt me.
Okay.
I just need to calm down.
Alright.
Okay.
I hate this.
Baby, go up.
Where you at?
Please.
Baby, hide.
Oh, hey, I'm hiding.
Is this hiding?
I hate this.
Okay.
I just need a ride.
Oh, cold.
Cold.
Please.
Leave me.
Leave me alone.
Please.
I hate this.
I just don't want to sleep.
I just want to sleep.
Hello?
Oh, I'm so fucking anxious right now.
Okay.
To view my memories.
Alright.
What is this?
What are you?
The fuck?
Okay.
Down I go.
Baby, go down.
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
I hate this.
Okay.
This can't be scary anymore.
Yes.
Pick you up.
I pick you up.
Alright.
Now I can't be scared.
This is just a platformer now, right?
This isn't scary.
It's not dark anymore.
I'm not scared.
I'm gonna speed run.
What's that doing here?
Oh, see.
There's a house.
Look at that.
Isn't that pretty?
Dude, this is like less scary than the fucking... my own house.
This is less scary than my... than this baby's house right now.
Is it locked?
I might be able to open it from the inside.
Yeah.
Go in and bet, Teddy.
Man, we just getting started.
Oh my god.
I think I just spent like an hour playing a game... playing the fucking...
first ten minutes of a game.
I spent an hour playing ten minutes of a game.
God fucking baby, dude.
God damn baby.
Is this what it's here?
No.
It sounds like it's coming from behind this door.
There must be a way to open it.
It seems like...
These are connected somehow.
Oh my god.
My heart.
I don't know how I'm gonna do the last... the last two scary streams, chat.
I'm... I'm...
Maybe it requires some sort of key.
Is there anything we can use?
I really got into that... that baby mentality.
Baby.
Okay.
Oh my god.
You know, bring me back to Little Nightmares.
I'd rather fucking play Little Nightmares than this shit.
This first person shit... this... this first person shit is too much, dude.
I can't even chase my Mr. Long Arms.
Buttons.
You're like, gaga goop.
I just...
Sorry.
Shut up.
I'm vlogging.
What happened?
Why didn't it open?
I played...
No.
There's no stream tomorrow.
Oh my god.
There's definitely...
There's definitely no stream tomorrow, chat.
I'd rather fucking...
We have to press both at the same time.
Both at the same time?
Oh.
That's it.
I was like, what do you mean?
Where's the button?
See?
Yeah, Layers of Fear is gonna be a fucking sub goal.
There is no fucking way I am playing Layers... Layers of Fear.
No, I streamed yesterday so...
It's just cause I was for the sub goal.
But holy...
I am not streaming Layers of Fear unless...
Unless it's a sub goal.
There is...
There's no fucking way.
Fucking...
There is no way I am fucking playing Layers of Fear after that.
Dude, no.
Not P.T.
I've watched gameplay of P.T., dude.
There is no way I am playing P.T.
There is no fucking way.
That lady...
Dude, that lady, dude.
I thought the other lady...
The other lady was scary but that lady...
Oh my god.
I don't wanna go in.
Why did they...
Why did the music stop?
I hate this.
I hate this music.
Okay.
How many subs?
Why did you like that earlier?
Why didn't you like that earlier?
What did we learn?
A f***ing baby!
That's the only thing I learned about this game!
Okay.
Okay, this is not scary.
I'm not at home.
Oh my god, I hate it when the baby makes sounds when he's climbing.
I hate this.
Baby, please stop making... please stop... I think I believe in you!
Thank you so much for the five bits, Plana!
Thank you!
Oh hey, what are you?
Baby... baby... baby...
Thank you, thank you for the five bits!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, does it just... oh, it just keeps going!
Please stop making sounds!
Okay.
Baby run, baby hide, baby smile...
Okay, I think one... I don't think one of them is the right... is the right...
Baby spin!
Baby spin.
Okay.
Oh my god.
A memory?
Oh, memory is good!
Memory is good!
Memory means not scary!
Memory good!
Is there a way up this tower?
Okay.
Oh, memory good.
Puzzle!
Puzzle no scary!
Oh, thank god!
Thank god it's puzzle!
That... oh!
Hey, Panda!
Nothing scary about a playground.
Nothing scary about that!
Oh my god.
Why is there...
Okay, okay, where is just this?
Okay, I was gonna be like, do I need to hide?
Do I need to hide or something?
Oh, oh...
Ah!
What the...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I crawl, I crawl, I crawl, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, bye!
Bear!
Hug!
I'm sick.
Oh, why is it dark?
Why are you dark?
It's okay, I hug.
I hug.
Oh, oh, it's saved.
I don't like that it's saved.
I don't like that!
How do I get up?
How do I... that wasn't even my phone.
That wasn't my phone.
How do I... how do I get up?
Oh, I don't know how that's... that's how I get up.
I don't like puzzles, baby don't like puzzles.
Baby... baby can't think right now.
Baby can't think.
Please don't make baby think.
What do I...
Please... oh, baby think.
Baby's thinking.
Please.
Wait.
What was that sound?
Oh... oh, I have to go in here.
Baby's stupid.
Baby's stupid right now.
Look, my brain's still developing, guys.
Baby brain's...
Baby's brain... is still developing.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Why are you scared?
Why are you scared, baby?
Baby, stop being scared!
Stop this!
Hold on, sorry, there's no wrinkle zone.
Anyone find... find...
This creeps me out.
I hope your mother is okay.
Who's this?
Oh... oh... oh... down?
Oh... did I die?
Did baby... oh, baby died!
I was like, down!
I thought we were supposed to go down!
I was like, yeah, down!
We're baby!
Okay.
Clearly, it was not... I... okay.
It was not down.
It wasn't down.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, there's another entrance.
What the...
Oh, what the fuck is... I thought that was like... what the fuck is wrong with this?
Okay.
How can baby die?
What?
Get out.
Well, like...
I hate this.
I... oh... you should try... I've never... dude, I... no!
No!
I can barely function right now!
As a baby!
I can't even function as a baby!
Let alone...
I have one more video card!
Baby!
One more.
I have one more??
Oh my god.
I have two more!
What the fuck's wrong with you, baby?
Baby can't count, chat.
Baby can't count.
I thought we... I thought we established that.
Now, you're gonna have to give us a chance to...
Baby doesn't know how to count.
My brain cannot process that.
What the fuck was that for?
Oh it's because it's hand turned.
Okay.
Where's the owl?
Owl?
What the fuck?
Where the fuck's the owl?
Why did it make baby climb?
Please stop screaming.
Please.
I don't know what you want from me.
I don't...
I'll scream back.
Please just stop.
I'm so go...
Is that it?
Oh there it is.
There you go.
There it is.
There you are.
Baby's smart.
Please stop.
I'm running.
Please stop falling.
Please.
No anymore.
I keep forgetting that anyone was there.
Where's the last one?
Ah.
Here?
Wait is that it?
Owl?
Is that you?
Oh no.
That's just rocks.
Why?
Where the fuck is the last...
my lifeblood?
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you!
Have a... have a butt heart!
Have a butt heart!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I have this... where the fuck is the last one?
Where are you?
Uhhh... up?
Up.
Up!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh...
No fear.
Just... just actions.
Head empty.
I've been released as one AIM.
Can't sleep.
So you gotta go the fuck to sleep.
What the fuck?
Why are you watching me try to play a scary game?
You're not gonna be sleeping anytime soon.
Watching this.
Yes, where she be running?
I've been running so...
I've been running...
Oh my god.
No.
Yeah, cause this stream is not gonna get you to sleep.
So you gotta...
This is... this stream...
Oh...
Ah!
All fear.
Panda, thank you so much for the five bits.
Oh my
god.
Where is it?
So much fear.
There is so much fear in me.
There is...
Haha!
Dude, I should probably sleep with two...
But this is too fast.
Where the fuck is the last one?
Ah!
Here?
What the fuck is wrong with this?
Where are you?
Wow.
Ow.
Rock.
Get...
Rock, please.
Ah!
Oh.
Okay.
Why the fuck is a tire stronger than...
than a baby?
That's so stupid.
Oh,
this is the only hour we spend on here.
Baby run.
Baby.
Baby no run.
Baby run.
Baby running.
Baby's running.
Hahaha.
Baby.
Ah!
No!
Hahaha.
Baby.
Baby, please.
Please.
Baby.
Okay.
Thank God.
Where's tire's driving?
Is he driving on the floor?
Baby.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my God.
Wasn't even hard.
Baby's so fucking smart.
The tire had certain potential gravitational energy.
So it had the ability to move the rock.
Who only... Okay.
Why This is my heart beating, baby.
Please, stop.
Baby, you should not be scared right here.
You should be scared a lot longer than this.
Okay.
I hate this.
Baby, I fucking, I hate babies.
I've never hated a baby more than in my life now.
I've never... Okay, okay, we're in memories.
It's memory zone.
We're in memories town now.
Oh, thank god.
Can't be scary now.
Not scared because it's memory time.
Not scared because it's memories.
Woo!
Not scared anymore.
Yeah, I wanna hear the melody.
Woo!
You just scared of us because you can't hear us.
You killed them from falling.
Yeah, I don't... Memory.
Woo!
Can't be scared now.
Okay.
Oh god, please.
No.
Shit.
It's still memory?
It's still memory.
Oh my god.
I hate this so much.
Oh shit, thank god.
Memory!
Woo!
Okay.
I'll pick you up.
Pick you up.
Enter the...
Oh, memory city.
Can't be scared now.
Oh shit, yeah, you're right.
Shit.
Oh my god, I can't believe...
Pick him up.
Slap him.
It's time to get moving.
Oh my god, I need to hydrate.
I need to hydrate after that.
Holy fuck.
Don't be afraid.
You and me will work this all out together.
Oh god, I fucking hate my day.
The fuck?
Don't be afraid.
This is like... This is like... Just be better, forehead.
Just don't get spooked, forehead.
Stupid bear.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need one... Okay, I got the second one now.
I need two more.
I need two more and then I'm done.
Oh my god.
How long is this game again?
Hahaha.
Come on.
We have no time to lose.
There he is.
Oh my god, please bear, can you do it for me?
Hahaha.
Oh.
Man, this looks unbearable.
I don't know if I chose the famous portal here.
But he was like, yeah, dude, don't worry.
Oh god, why is this so dark?
Why is this so dark, bear?
I hate this.
I...
Hahaha.
Oh,
candle.
Give me the candle.
Oh, the candle.
Oh.
Oh shit, I can... Oh, I can do this.
Okay.
Okay, look.
Boop.
He's not saying I'm safe.
Okay.
Leer's a baby.
Hahaha.
This is the only thing that's keeping me sane right now.
This is the...
Oh, do we...
Ah!
What the...
What the fuck was that?
Oh, that was just my reflection.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Give me...
Let me give me a second here.
Let's just, let me process this real quick and yeah.
Calm down.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm truly baby.
I'm truly baby guys.
So you got the rest of the team covering the camp.
Can't do nothing on you.
I hate this.
I'm practically in layers of fear right now.
I don't like this.
I don't... I don't like this.
What are you... what are you... what the... Peter!
I'm fucking... fucking Peter.
I didn't think about keeping quiet until now.
I didn't think about it.
Okay.
It is my serious regret to inform you that we have lost Rain to the void.
They will not be coming back ever.
So please send them your love now before they go.
Rest in peace my dear Braydyne.
Okay.
Why is there shit?
Why are there trees?
Why the fuck are there trees in here?
Okay.
Baby.
We're okay.
Baby okay.
Why did it change?
Okay.
Okay now we're outside.
Outside can't hurt us.
Okay I said that but then we were in the playground last time.
Those floaty things.
They look like memories.
Memories!
Memories can't hurt us!
Climb those roots.
Memories can't hurt us.
Let me out.
Let me... what the fuck?
Climb!
Memory!
I need my... oh.
Oh what the fuck is this?
What?
I can climb this.
No.
No!
I want memory!
Not puzzles!
I wanted memories not puzzles!
Oh no.
I need three puzzles.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Why are there paintings?
I fucking left layers of fear and they're giving me paintings again.
Why are they giving me paintings again?
I fucking left paintings.
I left paintings.
How do I fucking get out?
Do I crawl?
Baby crawl?
Baby?
Baby no.
Oh chair!
Chair.
Okay okay I just need a...
Yeah that's... baby got this.
Baby strong.
Baby please.
Okay maybe not cheer.
Send those braids to everyone.
You got this puzzle.
Oh oh oh.
Yeah?
Okay no.
Okay that wasn't it.
That was... oh oh.
Baby strong.
Okay.
Alright baby you got this.
Okay maybe that wasn't it.
Maybe baby doesn't got this.
What the fuck am I supposed to do baby?
My brain is still developing.
I don't know shit.
Am I really stuck on...
Baby so smart.
Hey that's alright.
You thought you got me.
I'm a smart baby.
Baby okay I might be blind but I'm smart.
What's the real MVP there?
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Oh oh oh dark.
Good morning Arkanoid.
Baby Mario.
Baby pole?
Baby.
Okay maybe that's not it.
Okay okay.
Ah!
Water.
I can't water.
Ah!
What is this game?
I don't... I'm... I'm baby.
That's what this game is about.
I'm a little baby.
Push.
Hey baby.
You got this baby.
Alright.
Alright who's still...
Thanks for hanging out with us today.
I... I hope you... I hope you enjoyed baby stream.
I hope...
Oh I hate this.
I... Why... Why do people play horror games?
What the fuck is wrong with all of us?
What is wrong with us?
I don't even know how far we are.
Is this a sad boy?
What the fuck?
Oh my god he's a sad boy.
Stupid bee.
I hate this.
I think... I think she...
Am I halfway?
Push.
Baby push.
Oh I don't fucking need you Teddy.
What do I do with this?
Box.
Baby push.
Baby...
What the fuck do I do with you?
Box.
Yeah okay.
How the fuck am I able to push a box but not a rock earlier?
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
This is so inconsistent.
I can fucking push a box but not a rock.
Because a rock made of rock.
But box is box.
What the fuck?
There.
What the...
Stupid baby.
Baby.
Baby drowned.
Oh my god where did it take me?
Where am I?
Oh.
Baby climbing in.
Are babies supposed to be really...
Oh yeah.
Apparently babies are supposed to be really good swimmers.
Okay.
Well my box is still there.
I'm just gonna jump.
Why the fuck do I even need a box?
I could've just fucking did that.
What?
I'm just gonna jump.
I didn't even need the box in the first place.
I could've just ran and landed on here.
God this is so stupid.
Okay.
Box.
Oh.
Push box.
What?
What are heroes even babies can play?
What the fuck?
Oh god actually.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to push a box.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I touched him.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I don't know if you guys heard that sound.
When I touched him it made a spooky noise.
I don't know.
It made a spooky noise when I touched it.
Oh.
Open.
There you are.
How do I get out?
Let me out.
Let me out of here.
Let me...
I hate the sound he makes when he's climbing.
Stop please.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna run so he's not gonna come a long way.
Oh!
Ah!
Guys, you can save ULU voice- We are not saving ULU voice- for layers of fear.
I forbid it.
I fucking forbid this shit.
Okay.
I'll refund everyone if it fucking gets to- Baby,
please be faster.
Baby, please.
I don't like this.
I don't like all this sound.
Baby.
Get in here.
Get in there!
Get in the fuck in there!
Fucking- Oh my god!
Why did it take him 20 years to get in?
Okay.
God, Bear, you're not helping me at all.
Bear, please.
Why aren't you helping me?
Why are you giving me negative reinforcements?
What the fuck?
My beard sucks!
You're getting out there making me feel like shit!
Sucking- Oh my god!
Why is- Oh!
What is wrong with this painting?
Look at it!
Why the fuck is her head gone?
Monster time?
Wait.
Wait, what?
Wait!
Wait.
What the fuck?
The painting changed.
What?
I didn't even notice that!
Oh my god!
I don't want to.
I don't like this chat.
Is he still safe?
Oh my god!
What?
There's...
No!
I was just playing each of like 10 different horror games.
Dude, honestly, honestly I'm down for that.
Oh my god.
Is there actually monsters?
Is it actually monster time through this door?
Through this painting?
Is it actually monsters?
Fucking backseat this.
I don't care anymore.
I need to know.
Please.
Please, I don't wanna.
Please chat.
Riffle.
You go through this bomb.
Oh my god.
You have a 500 bits...
I...
I feel like you should try playing some free indie games or something.
They're a whole lot less scary and more funny than anything.
Chat doesn't know I fucking hate all of you.
Okay, I'm going.
Ah!
This is layers of fear.
This is layers of fear!
You fucking... This is layers of fear!
I looked in and it stared back at me.
There's a fear but you're a baby.
Fucking not psychological horror in my fucking ass.
I don't know what you said.
Layers of fear.
I've been lied to.
It neverminds.
Layers of fear.
You're just playing as yourself.
Baby.
Baby and layers of fear.
We didn't try layers of fear.
And then...
And then this shit happened.
And then there's no more layers of fear anymore.
Layers of fear is a fucking sub goal now.
After what happened.
I hate this.
Okay, I need someone that's not gonna fuck with me.
And tell me, are there monsters in this?
I need a fucking no.
Right now.
Is there monsters in this level?
In this particular level?
Is there monsters?
Is there monsters in this level?
I don't fucking trust you, Gamble.
You've just been there being like...
Hey, is there scare notifications?
After you said that, I don't fucking trust you.
Hahaha
Of course not.
Smile, no smile.
Hahahahaha They find...
Monsters.
Am I gonna...
die when a fucking thing touches me in here.
Like...
Am I gonna...
Like not...
Like I know there's no fucking fall damage anymore.
Because I'm not inside water now.
But are there monsters that's gonna touch me.
Touch me and then I'm gonna die.
I hate all of you.
What if you just don't get caught?
I think the stranger shows up here.
Water is the truth.
I hate all of you.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Why did I play a scary game at 1 in the morning?
Why did I do this to myself?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I... fucking baby.
I stood here for so long, I forgot the baby makes a noise when you climb.
Oh my god, baby.
I hate you.
The way I'm feeling this is spiritual.
Oh, why is this layers of fear?
I left layers of fear for baby.
I fucking hate you, baby.
You're fine for now?
For now.
Okay, 10 minutes.
That's like 30 minutes.
Okay, that's good.
That's like 30 minutes then.
Crawl.
Baby.
My teddy bear.
I fucking hate my teddy bear.
He's fucking useless.
He's only here to be like, you should be quiet.
I think there's something wrong.
Oh my god.
I didn't learn some fear yesterday.
I've been screaming at almost everything.
I can get past the fucking staircase, Yumi.
I...
I thought doors were your alley, you know?
You had your doors in my car.
Oh yeah, I screamed at the same...
Ah!
I
hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Shoe.
Fucking shoe!
Stop fucking... Stop this stupid fucking game.
Fuck this
shoe.
Actually, fuck this shoe.
Fuck this shoe.
I hear my dog's... my dad's dog barking outside for a second.
I thought she came inside, but it was you screaming at this.
Okay.
Alright.
Chair.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for pushing the chair.
I am so sorry.
Okay.
We're good.
That's good enough.
See, the bear led us here to our doom.
God.
I've been enjoying the game.
I...
I don't know if enjoying is the right word right now.
I don't know if it's the right word.
Okay.
I crawl.
Everything is fine.
Get me up off this chair.
What?
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Please!
I am so sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry.
Oh,
my beard didn't say shit!
The beard didn't say shit!
Stupid fucking beard.
Why does my beard say shit when the monster is here?
What do I do?
Please, please, please.
Please let me in.
Please, I'm a baby.
I'm a baby, let me in.
I don't know what to do.
I don't want to get up.
I don't want to...
I don't want to fucking stand up there anymore.
I'm a baby, let me in.
Please.
I've been through so much.
I've been through so much, please let me in.
I don't know what to do.
What the fuck?
It worked.
It actually let me in.
What the fuck?
That crazy ass thing.
It gave them so bad for me.
Look at that.
All you have to do is just cry in front of a door.
And it opens.
Oh my god, you're right.
I tried after that.
Okay.
Do I crawl or stand up?
I don't want to go anymore.
After I saw that monster.
I don't want to keep going.
Okay.
Why is it so dark?
Ah!
Emmet.
He's the one with the gifted sub to Sessala.
Can we get some bark?
Emmet.
Oh,
my God, my tracker is bucking up.
Okay.
Down.
What is that sound?
No.
I might be scared.
Oh god there it is.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
So what are you playing?
Pass...
Phantasm... Okay.
If I say I'm... Oh no.
It's so well.
No it's so well.
I need to go out.
I'm in the rain.
Thank you.
I hope you had a good stream.
We were playing... Oh my god.
Okay.
Ah!
I'm sorry she's having a mental breakdown.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Don and Nick.
Thank you.
I'm a putter.
Thank you so much.
I don't get to show you guys... Oh god.
I am not having a good time right now.
She's so cute.
Thank you.
Thank you for the follow.
Gaming and social.
Have a great point, arts.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm baby.
I am baby.
I... Oh god!
What the fuck?
I hate this.
Thank you for the follow to Carol.
Thank you.
I have so worried.
I have so worried about hearts.
We... Okay.
Okay.
We got this.
I'm baby.
I'm... I'm baby.
I'm out.
Oh god.
This is the well.
This is the freaky well.
Ah!
I see.
I see someone.
What is your first impression of a do you have a crisis crime?
Wanting to die, got to go.
Oh God, please!
Wait, down?
Down, down, down!
Okay,
okay.
I thought down was the answer.
Thank you for the follow.
Tycy, Zoan, and Hollows.
Thank you, have some more fun.
You good at gate here?
Okay, okay, look.
I never said horror...
I never said horror was a game I'm good at.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I need to figure out how to...
Please let me crawl.
At least a mental breakdown.
This is a crazy lady.
Okay, up.
Up.
Ah!
Oh, I turned.
Oh.
Please, why can't you pull faster?
Why can't you pull faster, you stupid baby?
Ah, please, baby!
I'm done.
Baby's done.
Let baby out.
Let baby out!
Please let me out!
Why?
Why did this...
Why did this change?
Why?
Why did the music change?
Bear!
Thank you for the follow, Milky.
Thank you.
Uh...
Hey...
Where do
I go?
It can't hurt me.
Doesn't it get hurt me?
Where's the crazy lady?
Where is she?
God, where is she?
How do I get out of here?
Please, I just wanna...
I just wanna get out of here, please.
I hate this.
Please, let me out.
Please, just let me out.
Please.
Okay.
Everything will be fine.
You're okay.
Oh god.
You're perfectly fine.
You are perfectly fine.
You're baby.
Oh my god.
I'm a perfect baby.
Baby fine.
Where the fuck does this wor- Where does it want me to go?
Oh.
It was here all along.
Look, my brain's still developing.
I'm still- Oh my god.
I'm fucking- I'm so stupid.
This baby is crazy.
Okay.
Let me out.
Let baby out.
Let baby- Wait.
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh there.
Let baby out.
Please.
Let baby- Climb.
Oh god.
Let me out.
Okay.
Oh god... Now run!
AHH!
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU?!
I'm running!
Baby running!
Baby run!
Baby...
Baby crawl.
Baby's crawling.
Baby crawl!
Where's the monster?
Where is she?
Who the fuck told me that there were no monsters?
Who was it?
Who said there were no monsters in this level?
In this specific level?
Oh my god.
Moonlight, Fox, thank you so much for the follow.
Apple butter.
What are the monsters?
What are the friends we made along the...
There are no monsters.
What the fuck do you mean?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Alright.
Fuck you, Nintendo.
Okay.
Um...
As all of you here, I just forgot to check on the hot switch as well.
Okay.
Baby crawl.
I
don't know where to go!
Okay...
Calming down... Baby's calming down...
Okay.
Baby in barrel.
Baby...
Just get out of here.
Pissing you.
Baby just keep crawling baby...
Just keep crawling baby...
JUST KEEP CRAWLING BABY!
Just...
Nothing can hurt you.
Nothing can hurt you baby!
Just... just ignore everything.
Just... Just think...
Get get get get get get...
Get!
Please!
Oh God!
I'm okay.
Oh my God, Jacob.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Thank you for the follow.
I'm a...
I'm a footer.
No.
I'm just very scared.
I'm just very, very, very fucking scared right now.
Okay.
Why are they knocking?
Why is there knocking?
I'm halfway!
I still have halfway left to the end of this puzzle?
I'm sorry.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
I hate this so much, chat.
Chat, I want you to know...
I took my headphones off.
My headphones are off right now.
I'm getting...
I don't want to hear any more knocking.
I'm 80 weak.
Baby's very weak right now.
Okay.
Who's knocking at me?
Okay, how do I get up?
Oh God.
I fucking hate you guys.
I hate...
I'm going back in my barrel.
Okay, I'm putting it back on.
I'm putting my headphones back on, chat.
I...
You guys are making it worse when you're typing the fucking sound.
Fucking...
I live in barrel.
This is my home.
This is my home now.
I have everything I need.
Ah!
Please stop knocking.
Please.
Please stop knocking the door.
Okay.
Alright.
Baby, go up.
Oh God.
Baby, please.
Okay.
How do baby go up?
Baby's strong.
We're barrel people.
I did.
I put my headphones back on.
I put it back on.
Okay.
Oh God.
That was my shadow.
That was my fucking...
Ah!
Fucking baby!
Bear!
I love you.
Am I safe?
Am I safe now?
I don't wanna go turn around.
I don't wanna turn around chat.
Okay.
Turn around... They have to really require you to use... oh yeah, Toshi.
I'm so sad right now.
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
Koby, thank you so much for the five bits.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Baby sad.
Can I come out now?
Can I turn around now?
I'm barrel.
I'm barrel baby now.
I live with the barrel.
Okay.
Alright.
I am strong baby.
I am... I'm strong berry.
How do I get out?
How do I... How do I get out?
How do I...
Okay.
A strong infant baby who don't need... No, I need my bear.
I need my fucking bear.
I need my fucking bear, guys.
Okay.
Fine.
Wait, where...
Barrel.
A barrel.
Where do I go?
I don't know where to go.
Barrel is my only safe spot right now.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Where do I go after I get key?
I don't know where to go after I get key.
I don't wanna go out with the monster.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Okay, okay, okay.
Right or left?
Do I go this way?
Or do I go this way?
There's a locked gate?
Where the fuck's the locked gate?
I think I deleted it.
The memory of the locked gate.
I'm baby lost.
Baby is so lost.
Where the fuck's the locked gate?
Okay.
Which way?
Where's the gate?
I don't even remember there being a gate.
When the fuck did I see a gate?
I just go right?
Baby's just gonna go right.
Oh, right is dead end.
I wanna take off my headphones again till we get there.
Okay.
When you try to run away near the wall.
Where the fuck?
What wall?
I had to wear walls?
What?
I don't remember shit.
I don't remember what walls.
Oh my god.
Just because I hate this.
I'm going back inside.
She can't get me here yet.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do.
I don't...
Okay.
I hate this.
Me.
I... I hate this so much.
The wall was... There was spider balls?
I paint the walls.
Where's the wall?
I already did that.
Yeah, already did that.
Where's the wall?
Do I go... right?
Or forward?
I don't know forward or way?
But I don't know where to go.
Alex!
Alex, help me!
I'm so scared, Alex!
Baby must explore!
No, please don't make baby do...
Alex, save me!
Save me from this tree!
Okay, okay, just go forward.
Forward leads to nowhere!
Alex, okay, wait, wait.
Oh no, that's the dead end.
You just...
Forward leads me to nowhere, but I can push.
Push.
Okay.
Wait, I'm AD strafing.
I'm strafing.
Okay, where the fuck do I go?
Push.
I'm okay, I'm safe.
Okay, chat.
Barrel, barrel, barrel, barrel.
Okay.
Barrel.
Oh, oh, ah!
I gotta call the IRL's side of this weird appearance.
We miss you, Alex!
We miss you.
Am I going the right way?
Guys, please tell me I'm going the right way.
Because if I am not going the fucking right way, I'm going the right way.
Left?!
Left?
Left is ocean.
Left is...
Where the fuck am I going?
Hole?
Can I go through hole?
No, I don't...
I...
I don't know where.
I don't know where to go.
I may be lost.
I don't know where.
Maybe he don't know where.
Maybe he just wants to stop.
Okay.
Am I going the right way?
Oh,
which way do we go?
Chad, please help me!
I don't want to explore anymore!
I don't want to explore, please!
Please, I don't want to explore anymore!
This is like he take baby, put baby on back and carry me off.
Hahaha!
Hydra Mom!
Why did you have to give it a name?
Why did you have to?
Why did you have to give her a name?
That makes it worse!
Why did you have to give Hydra Mom a name?
I just wanted to call her the what the fuck.
Please, put baby on back and tell her where baby go.
I can't.
I don't want to go.
I don't want to explore anymore.
Fucking, fucking, fucking backseat me so hard, please.
Hahaha!
Like, what the, what the fuck, Mom?
Her name is Lady of the Forest.
Baby's gonna be in bush forever if someone does not fucking take up the backseat gaming.
Hahaha!
Go for it and go, right?
If you can't see them, they can't, I don't think that's the right logic.
I don't think, I don't think, hahaha!
I don't think that's, that's the right logic here.
Hahaha!
Let's go right?
We've been here.
Baby's been here though.
Baby been right?
Baby, baby, baby scared.
Baby scared!
What was that?
Can't see me if I'm in the bush.
Can't see me.
Branch.
Why the fuck can I carry a branch now?
What is this branch gonna do?
Baby have weapon?
Baby have weapon.
Okay.
Alright, any backseat gamers in chat?
Please, please backseat.
Please, I just, I just wanna get out of here.
Hahaha!
I've been stuck here for so long.
I just don't, I don't wanna keep, I don't wanna go the wrong way.
Oh, that's what made the noise.
That's so fucking stupid.
Oh, branch gone.
Oh no, branch gone.
Hahaha!
Okay.
My mind's gone.
Yeah, Lancer's right, my mind's gone too.
My mind's gone already.
What you playing?
What you, what you, what you, what you playing?
Hahaha!
I hope she won't, I, you know, I don't even fucking, I can't even trust chat anymore.
I can't even fucking trust you guys when you say, when you're like, don't worry, the monster's gone already.
You don't have to worry about anything.
And then fucking, you're like, don't worry guys, there's no monster in this, in this level, you're fine.
And now you guys are like, don't worry, the monster's gone.
I don't think I can trust you guys anymore after that.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Need some, oh god, I need more than just brain cells.
Okay, I'm taking my, shit, fuck this, I'm taking my headphones off.
Fuck this, if I'm gonna have to deal with a monster, I'm gonna have to, I'm gonna have to explore this by myself.
I'm gonna fucking, I'm fucking, I'm fucking taking my headphones off.
Headphones off now.
Headphones off.
I'm about to explore this by myself.
Fucking taking my headphones off.
Oh my god.
I won't even know if the monster's gonna come out.
I can't even hear shit!
Hahaha!
Can't hear shit!
Can't hear, hurt me!
Wooo!
Oh, there it is.
All I have to do is just take my headphones off.
Hahaha!
What?
Monster's behind me?
You think I give a fuck?
Yeah!
I don't care, I can even stand.
Ho-ho-ho!
Ho-ho!
Ha-ha-ha,
ha -ha-ha-ha-ha-haaa!
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
A-ha-ha-ha!
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ah-ha-ha-ha!
Ssh!
My god.
Whoa!
I hate all of you!
Oh don't worry, the monster is gone.
You can fucking explore the forest.
I was like, yeah I'm not scared.
I can stand on them too.
I'm not scared.
Oh my god.
I can't fucking believe it.
I fucking can't believe that.
I was like, yeah look at me.
I can stand up too.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I hate all of you.
Okay, okay.
Alright, well now I know what the fuck's gonna happen after that.
Okay, is there a way to avoid this monster?
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Do I just have to get the key or do the key thing really fucking fast?
Is that it?
Is that all I have to do?
Is that all?
I'm not gonna put my headphones back on after that.
If I die, I die I guess.
Do I just have to like run super fast and then plug the key in and that's all?
Please, please chat.
Yes, of course this is...
We've been lost here for so long.
For like 30 minutes we've been stuck in this fucking one level.
For 30 minutes.
Of course this is the fucking first time.
Okay.
So I just have to do the thing very fast because I'm not doing this like 20 times.
If you guys are fucking giving me... Okay, which way though?
I forgot I fucking got lost already.
Okay.
Baby fast.
Baby please.
You gotta be faster than that baby.
Please baby.
Baby.
Please.
Baby's tied up.
Baby.
Why can't I open this?
Baby!
Oh god.
Baby.
Baby just keep running.
Just keep running.
I don't know where to run.
Baby just...
Baby.
Oh god.
Just keep running.
Oh.
Oh!
Baby
up.
Baby up.
Baby.
Baby stop.
Stop crawling.
Please.
Just stop crawling.
Just get out.
Baby.
Just get the fuck out.
Please.
Guys.
Baby did it.
Baby sit down for a sec.
Baby's just gonna sit down.
Sit down for a sec.
Chat.
I just... I just sit down for a sec.
I sit down for a sec.
Baby Baby overcome some fear.
Oh my god.
I hate...
Baby.
Baby's just vibing right now.
Okay, time to put the last puzzle piece.
Oh god.
God I hate you so much baby.
I fucking hate you so much.
The last level.
The last one.
Come on.
Is this last monster gonna chase me too?
Is the last monster gonna chase me too?
I need to know.
The dress code in the beginning probably.
To be fair to me, the previous monster didn't chase you.
More like it snuck up on you.
Oh my god.
How the fuck... Oh my god I hate this.
I hate this.
Alright, how's this painting gonna change?
How are you gonna change?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why do you not have a face?
Where the fuck's your face?
I don't...
I don't know if I can keep doing this guys.
I don't know if I...
I don't know if I can keep doing this.
I think...
Chat...
I think I'm gonna...
I'm gonna end stream here.
I can't.
I...
I can't dude.
This last 20 minutes.
20 minutes of hell.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We believe in you.
I don't believe in myself though guys.
I...
I don't believe in myself chat.
Just take off my clothes.
Just revert to Ooga Booga mode like you did.
I was like Ooga Booga mode.
It's gonna help me here in stream.
Okay.
I hate this.
20 minutes of hell.
It's kinda funny.
Okay.
How about this chat?
We finish.
We'll do another 3 hour stream for this game next stream.
How about that guys?
Is that better?
Can we double that?
I can't.
I'm looking into this fucking...
I'm looking into this void right now.
I just can't.
This void... this void is fucking with me right now.
Please... guys please... I don't think I can keep going.
I don't think I can go through this void right now chat.
Weird...
Oh god... oh my god... stop whining!
Dude!
What the fuck?
You play this game yourself Arizona!
Why can't you try to play this game?
Iflable... fuck you fable!
Iflable how could you do this to me?
How could you?
How could you do this to me iflable?
Also time fucking Arizona out!
Dude!
That actually fucking made me so mad!
Stop fucking whining!
Bitch!
Holy shit!
That is so fucking rude!
Oh my god... fable... fable... how could you do this to me?
How could you fucking do this to me fable?
I love you... but how could you do this to me?
Thank you so much for the five bits fluffy!
Thank you!
Okay... alright...
We're going in...
This is for fable...
This is...
Dror...
Let me just sit in my chair for a bit...
No I'm wearing my headphones right now...
Let me sit in my chair for a bit...
I need to... I need to process this right now...
I need to fucking process this...
Hahaha...
Is this a maze?
Do you have to try and get out of the fucking maze?
What the fuck is this?
Hahaha...
How do you get in front of a maze?
Where the... Oh my god...
Oh my god!
Alright, someone fucking pull me a fucking picture of the maze right now...
And then tell me where to go...
Oh my god!
Ninten!
Thank you so much!
For the six gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Give me some park nights real quick!
For Ninten!
For the six gifted subs!
Thank you so much!
Okay.
Cute avatar, thank you!
Thank you!
Okay.
Alright, I'm taking my headphones off.
Dude, dude.
This is a fucking maze!
I can't!
If you want me to fucking solve a maze right now, I'm not wearing my headphones for this shit.
Alright.
Time to solve a maze.
Oh my god, Stupa!
Thank you for the rain!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I'm going crazy right now!
I'm going crazy!
Thank you for the rain!
Oh!
I'm getting spooked so hard!
I- my headphones are off.
My headphones are fucking off right now!
Cause they made me fucking finish this last puzzle.
And I can't.
They put me in a maze.
I'm in a fucking maze right now, Stupa.
I'm in a fucking maze!
I ain't wearing my headphones!
I'm wearing my headphones for this shit.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Doo doo doo.
I don't know where to go!
Just kill me!
Please!
Thank
you for the follow blogs!
Thank you!
I'm playing on PC right now...
I can't...
You guys are like, don't worry, it's a maze.
Fucking go... and you're like, doot doot doot!
Oh my god.
Like I said, fucking co- don't worry, it's just a code man.
Don't worry, the sea monster girl, the fucking, what's her name, Hydra mom is not gonna get you anymore, she's gone!
I can doot doot doot into her!
I can doot doot doot right into her!
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't go straight.
What I've learned...
is that...
I just don't go straight.
Can someone fucking back the game for me?
Okay.
Alright, so apparently...
I don't go straight.
Apparently...
Yeah, I meant my daily, I'll do that later.
I need to process this first.
Oh my god.
Which way do I go?
If I don't go straight, I guess left?
Okay, I need to go left.
And then Hydra mom's in front of me.
Okay.
Alright.
Here she is!
Oh, doot doot doot!
Doot doot doot!
Please!
Where am I going?
I can't hear anything!
Let me through!
Oh, I won't let me through!
Please let me through!
Oh, people!
Doot doot doot!
Bed, bed, bed, bed!
It can't kill me if I'm under bed!
Oh!
Please just leave.
They gave me 100 beds, people!
The fuck do I go?
Okay, I'm just gonna stay here for a bit, guys.
Okay.
I don't know where to go after this.
Where the fuck do I go?
Where the fuck?
I have to go back out.
Okay, let me...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna drink water real quick, guys.
I'm just gonna sit in my water.
For a second while I process what to do after.
We live here.
This is my home now.
Barrel is not my home anymore.
I've upgraded from barrels.
From the barrel home.
I've upgraded.
Okay.
Barrel baby's in bed, baby!
I'm bed baby now, guys.
I'm bed baby now.
END IT!
Jericho, where do I go, Jericho?
Fucking just tell me where to go.
Jericho just tell me where to go.
You know how to end this.
You know how to end this, Jericho.
I don't want to go.
I don't want to go out.
This is freaking fucking...
Let me breathe in.
Okay.
It's time.
Oh my god, I hate you guys.
Okay.
I'm going back.
I'm going back because I don't know where to go.
Oh god, please.
It's over here.
That's it, right?
Over there, right?
It's over there, right?
I see it.
Do
do do.
Do do do.
Next memory.
Fucking run.
Oh god.
Oh fuck you.
Oh my god.
A rabbit cried and cried.
He cried so much.
And his tears filled the bottom of the well.
That was me.
Give me that fucking book.
Give me that book.
Where the fuck am I?
Why is it sunny now?
Stop.
Oh god.
Let me in.
God, bring me back.
Bring me back home.
Oh my god.
We're back.
Get the fuck in my hand right now.
Get in my hand.
Oh baby, he's back.
What was that?
That thing?
What was that thing?
Shut the fuck up, bear.
You didn't know.
Oh, he's there.
She seems so sad and desperate.
All this bear did was give me fucking depression.
What the fuck?
He's just there.
He's never be like, you go.
You did it, child.
Good job.
No, he's just like, man.
That lady was so sad.
Oh my god.
I know.
Alright.
Time to close.
I saw you play spooky stuff and never clicked the Discord link that...
Oh, Vic, I'm so sorry.
We're about to...
We just finished our last level today.
Yeah, we're finishing.
I'm not going through another level right now.
It's fucking 4 AM, chat.
It's 4 AM.
Bear, I'm not fucking pushing that fucking button.
Alright.
We're gonna...
I'm just gonna sit down for a sec, guys.
Okay.
No.
No, we're gonna...
I'm finishing this game next stream.
There is no fucking way.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Because there's still the memory and...
And, like...
A level after...
Don't fucking fuck with me.
I know there's a level after the memory.
You think I don't know there's a level after the memory?
Don't fuck with me.
I might be baby.
But I know there's a level after the fucking memory.
She's cheating.
You know how I know?
Because there's no way it's gonna end.
When you're getting all the memories.
And being like, congratulations, you got all the memories.
And then, bam!
Boss level.
You think I don't know that shit?
You think I don't fucking know that shit?
Alright, guys.
I'm not gonna end right away.
I'll do the Q&A session.
I'm gonna do the Q&A session.
So, you know what?
I'm just gonna fucking...
I'm leaving.
I'm gonna be right back, chat.
You got no clarifiedutes you got?
You're not allowed to be on here.